oh nastiest girl I've ever been with was
um beautiful girl started normal you
know 6 months
in um she tell well it started with she
was on top of me in bed and she goes to
put a finger in my ass okay but I mean
there's no hint she's on facing the
other way she's reverse cowgirl so I
don't see it coming she reaches I don't
see it coming and she doesn't spit on it
nothing just a fam and I was like what
the
like it hurt I was like get off and then
we had this conversation where she was
in asspl I'm like that's fine but like
easing me into it a little bit yeah give
me a heads up spit on the like
you have nails you know what I mean you
have nails so you know what I
mean you have nail well and